ظهر فيديو من كاميرات المراقبة لامرأتين علقتا
في تبادل لإطلاق النار بين
مسلحي حماس والقوات الإسرائيلية خلال
هجوم على بلدة يحي في جنوب إسرائيل
بالقرب من حدود غزة. لا تستطيع شبكة CNN
التحقق بشكل مستقل مما حدث،
وتعتقد شبكة CNN أنهما ربما هربتا إلى هنا
من مهرجان نوفا.  بعد وقت قصير من
الهجوم الذي شنه مقاتلو حماس في وقت مبكر من
صباح يوم السبت، كان يحي على بعد حوالي 50 دقيقة بالسيارة
من موقع المهرجان. وصل مقاتلو المطرقة وتم
إخراج النساء من
البوابة لأسباب غير واضحة
في المسافة، ويظهر الفيديو
مقاتلين إسرائيليين يقتربون من النساء
لمحاولة لفت انتباههم ولكن يتعين عليهم
الانحناء أمام السيارة بينما يبدأ مسلحو حماس
[موسيقى]
إطلاق النار على النساء في
منتصف تبادل إطلاق النار مع تبادل إطلاق النار من
حولهن، ثم يفرون في النهاية مع
تغطية المقاتلين الإسرائيليين
لهن.